un confinement mais pas seulement
en guadeloupe un couvre-feu général est
instauré de 20h à 5h du matin depuis le
1er avril dans la foulée des premières
annonces du gouvernement des mesures de
protection forte ont été prises dès le
25 mars certains maires ont par exemple
appliquer un couvre-feu sur leur
territoire très rapidement les centres
hospitaliers se sont organisés pour
faire face aux risques d'augmentation
exponentielle des consultations en
réponse à cette pandémie
il ya une augmentation très
significative d'une part des lits de
médecine dédié à la filière qu'ovide
avec plusieurs unités qui ont été
ouvertes et qui permettrait
potentiellement l'accueil de plusieurs
dizaines de patients est en réanimation
on a pour l'instant ouvert deux unités
représentant au total 20 l'ico vide et
deux autres unités qui sont susceptibles
de faire monter la capacité jusqu'à 38
lits et si ça ne suffisait pas il ya
encore d'autres paliers on va dire de
réponse à cette infection comme en
métropole les supermarchés sont pris
d'assaut
face à la situation les habitants
redoutent des pénuries et n'hésitent pas
à acheter plus qu'à leur habitude
enfin on va pas se leurrer on va pas
dire que c'est c'est comme si les gens
achètent me dis-je pas achètent des
choses peut-être qu'ils ont pas besoin
j'achète 3 à manger d'un seul coup de
peur de manquer il achète trop de sarko
alors grippaux fait diffuser et à les
étaler les courses à face aux règles du
confinement mis en place depuis un mois
les guadeloupéens temps de trouver des
occupations
certains commencent à s'impatienter je
sors pas souvent mais quand lorsque je
sors je vois quand même pas mal de gens
sur la route ou sur
au supermarché bon supermarché ce un peu
indispensable mais je pense qu'il ya
quand même un petit peu un petit
relâchement parce que les gens en ont
quand même un peu marre du confinement
au niveau des études les profs nous
envoie quand même plutôt régulièrement
des cours ou des devoirs maison
d'enchères il y en a pas trop donc ça va
on n'est pas non plus chargés et ça me
laisse le temps de regarder mes petites
séries de titres comme ça sur une autre
île composé de trois communes les maires
ont pris un arrêté afin d'interdire les
accostages et débarquement de bateaux à
passagers sur les différents ports de
l'île une initiative que le préfet n'a
pas soutenu en saisissant le tribunal
administratif